Islamnet is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you because every person that comes
a step [music] closer to Allah through
your donation, you will inshallah be
reaping the reward. Click the link and
donate what you can.
Okay guys, assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
well inshallah. I'm here with
Smile to Jannah.
Assalamualaikum.
>> Alaikum salaam. I'm so tempted to say
your name but I'm going to smile. Okay.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Okay, so there's a video that's been
going viral of this rapper called
6ix9ine
and Neon. Yeah? Is it Neon his name? I
don't I don't know anything about him,
the brother. I don't know if I came in
here before.
Uh but there was
this video was going viral for the wrong
reasons and I feel like a lot of people
like you get those TikTok Muslims and
they follow the TikTok Islam, yeah?
It's become so distorted and warped like
they're rejecting Hadith but here it's
just as if like when someone says
something and it sounds cool, they're
like, "Oh, that must be the hook." It
doesn't work like that. Let's watch the
video cuz I found it very interesting
cuz I was like, "What's he trying to say
and what's Neon saying?" Cuz we know
Neon obviously he's not claiming to be a
person of Dawah or Islam knowledge etc.
He doesn't have that knowledge but was
what he saying true or was what 6ix9ine
saying is true? That's what you first
say. Are you ready?
Does Allah
accept that? No, but I can't say
anything because I'm Muslim and I do
this on stream. I promote this
on stream. So it's like we we can't be
we can't be perfect.
>> cool. You can't be perfect but take that
to Pakistan and see if you're if they
won't chop [music] your head off. Take
that to Khabib. Take that to Dagestan
and play with their religion.
>> But he never [music] said he was deep
into the religion though. It doesn't
matter. You can't be one foot in with
God and another foot out.
>> [music]
>> I get what you're saying but it's like
>> No, it's bro, if you if you believe in
God
you're all the way with God or you're
not with God at all.
>> That's not true because some people are
trying to figure out what they want, who
they are.
>> All right, if if Khabib [music] was
right here Khabib is different bro. He's
a full on Muslim locked in. He devoted
his life to that.
>> these people are half in Muslims.
They're not I mean he's new. He's just
proving my point. I mean what do you
make out cuz I've got my whole like just
want to ramble a bit, yeah? But the the
first thing that he said that I was
like, "Huh? What on earth is he going on
about?" He said, "Okay, so
if you're not perfect in your religion,
take that to Pakistan and they'll chop
your head off."
What a stupid thing to say. That doesn't
even make any sense. Like what? What are
you talking about? Are you trying to say
that if you're not perfect in Pakistan,
they will kill you? Like who Where have
you Where are you getting this from?
What does that even mean? Firstly,
Pakistan has secular law. Yes, it's the
Islamic Republic of Pakistan but they
don't enforce Sharia law. Secondly, if
you're not perfect you're not going to
be attacked in Pakistan cuz a lot of
Pakistan Pakistanis are not perfect. And
thirdly, he then went on to say uh yeah,
you can't have one foot in and one foot
out. Firstly, it's not binary. It's not
black and white, ones and zeros.
Islam is a journey, yeah? When you
accept Islam or you become practicing,
that's you starting your journey. Yes,
when you're starting your journey, you
shouldn't be exposing your sins and
mistakes publicly. You develop privately
and you do your things and if there's
something if you're an online
personality, then you don't say, "Oh,
I've got this opinion." Just like you
wouldn't talk about health issues
without your stream being affected or
you don't give any, you know, um
uh lawyer advice, you know, advice on
the law. Islam is the same. If you are
not knowledgeable, then don't talk about
it authoritatively,
yeah? You can obviously talk about how
it's affecting you and the likes but not
authoritatively.
And yes, you can be on your journey
making mistakes or whatnot but not
justifying those mistakes. Saying, "You
know what? This is an issue that I have.
I'm on my journey. Uh if you have any
advice for me, I'm willing to hear it,
blah blah blah." But to say, "No, no,
no, no. Either you're in either you're
doing everything or you're doing
nothing." No. In other words, like, "Oh,
if so-and-so has a hijab on and she's
doing take the hijab off. So-and-so's
got a beard and he's doing this, shave
the beard off." No.
Some people start working on their
outside and then start working on their
inside. Some people start working on
their inside and then start working on
their outside. Different people yeah,
different people are doing different
things but this whole notion cuz I saw
it as well that people are saying,
"Yeah, yeah, 6ix9ine knows Islam more
than this individual and this and that."
No, this is the problem. Even the
non-Muslims that we speak to, they
accept the precepts of Islam and even
the
you know, the fundamental points of
belief of Islam. However, they say,
"Yeah, we don't think we'll be able to
do justice. We don't think we'll be able
to give up alcohol and this and that."
Ladies and gentlemen, no, this is not
what Islam says that you have to be a
finished product for you to accept
Islam. No, Islam helps you become the
finished product.
>> you become a finished product when you
enter paradise. And this is really
important because we know many Hadith
narrations. For example, when Hatib ibn
Hatib ibn Abi Balta, when he wrote a
letter which was kind of seen as treason
or kind of spying which was not his
intention, um you could have come and
say, "Wow, treachery done. He's Forget
halfway half in one foot in one foot
out. He's not He's both feet out." When
you had for example the Sahaba who would
go and drink alcohol What did the
prophet say uh regarding Hatib ibn Abi
Balta?
>> well, when Hatib said, "Oh, messenger of
Allah, let me take his head off." But
the messenger uh the the the prophet
said, "No, for he indeed He said,
"I'tmalu ma shi'tum laqad wajabat lakum
al-jannah."
Which is? That means oh paraphrasing,
"Oh Umar, what do you know that Allah
has said regarding the people of Badr? I
have forgiven you.
Do as you please."
>> only that, subhanallah, so profound. Not
only that we had a companion who would
drink alcohol and he would be caught in
front of the messenger of Allah. He
would be whipped in public. And once one
of the companions said, "May Allah curse
you." And the prophet got so angry said,
"Don't say that to him for indeed he
loves Allah and his messenger." With
this ideology, this thought process of
And I understand where 6ix9ine is coming
from. He's coming from a It's like he
has a bit of a fear over God in the
sense where he's like, "Listen, don't
violate God's law." And this is the
biggest trick of Shaitan. You know why?
Because maybe 6ix9ine this is the reason
why you're not becoming a Muslim or
accepting Islam because you're thinking,
"Bro, I'm not ready to be fully in."
That's why I'm going to be fully out.
And we're saying no, in Islam even if
that means we're one toe in, that's
progress. One toe in bro is progress.
You know why? Cuz that toe is going to
enter the whole body into that You know
what's You know what's ironic? I think
Neon was saying, "Oh, would you convert
to Islam?" And and his response to that
was, "I'm Christian, bro."
So
Well, well, well, if you're a Christian
and the things that you're doing, well,
it seems like you're one foot one foot
in one foot out. So you need to Yeah,
exactly. So the thing No, it came from
you. So the point is what guys? That you
need to understand this is the biggest
trick of Shaitan and how this does
relate to you when you do sins. Two
wrongs don't make a right. If a sister
is not wearing the hijab, we don't say
to them don't pray salah. If a brother
is drinking alcohol, we don't come and
say to her don't do another deed of
helping your mom. That's stupid.
[laughter] Like what what kind of And
that it's not like that.
>> don't make a right, innit?
Uh Zeeshan, whose idea was it to have
you on the show uh video? Allah knows
best.
>> I forget to Yes,
>> [laughter]
>> it looks like I'm one foot in you're one
foot full full body out. Yes, so in a
nutshell, look, Neon was right. I'm so
sorry. What 6ix9ine said might have sou-
sounded good and uh No, no, no, sorry.
That is the trick of Shaitan to make you
believe you have to be perfect. And in
our religion, Islam is for the sinners.
Look, we don't do this Let me tell you
this. The reason why I have a Dawah
table in Leicester Square where there's
gambling they're having got those
intimacy outside on the road
>> You're doing on the Dawah table or what
Zeeshan? Oh, okay. Yeah. So gambling,
having intimacy outside on the road,
drinking alcohol, drugs, you name it.
And we are there because that is the
people that need Islam the most. What
should I do in front of a masjid and
call people who are coming to salah back
to salah? So you need to understand
Islam is there for the sinners and
paradise will be full of sinners. Yes?
And in order for you to get into
paradise, one foot needs to be in.
What's the more chance
likely for you to enter paradise with
one foot in or no foot in?
One something a progress has to be
there. And we know the Hadith of the
prophet Muhammad said he said Tell them.
That God Allah subhana wa ta'ala said,
"If mankind was not to sin, God almighty
would destroy them and bring forth a
nation that sins but repents." Okay? So
which shows what? God almighty does not
want sinless people. The key here is
what? Not that he wants you to sin. He's
making you acknowledge you're a sinner.
The key here is what? Repent. Bro, if
you don't sin, how are you going to be
humble in front of God? Why was Pharaoh
acting and saying I'm God? Because he
had money, wealth, power, everything. He
was saying I'm like God. I don't need
God.
>> "Ana rabbukum al-a'la. I am your lord
most high."
>> high. And guess what? That's the reason
why Allah
>> the most low. In exactly out of humility
to us all. When I commit my sins, I know
how vulnerable I am, how weak I am, how
I'm violating my own soul that I turn to
my creator. If I didn't do that, I'd
say, "What's the What's What do I need
for God for what? I don't commit sins."
So Islam is not for the angels, it's for
the sinners and here Neon is right
rather than 6ix9ine.
Why don't you come with Is it rap, yeah?
Yeah. Then I'm going to rap.
>> Oh, no.
>> 6ix 6ix9ine needs You need to come to
the straight line. Oh, no.
>> [laughter]
>> The Dawah that I give is mine.
Then what was the Dawah that
>> [laughter]
>> What's I'm not finished bro. All right.
The Dawah that I'm doing is like the
sun, it shine. Uh shines.
>> [laughter]
>> Can I just take the S out?
>> Wait, listen listen.
>> All right. I don't eat swine.
>> Mhm, he doesn't. I'm telling you he
doesn't. If I punch you in the face,
you'll have a broken spine.
But No, no. Me I I I don't commit a
crime.
Okay.
>> I like lemonade with lime. You actually
do. Yeah. All right, see I'm I'm I don't
I don't I don't I'm not lying.
>> You're not lying then.
But how do you punch the face and it
breaks the spine?
>> Cuz I'm so powerful.
And I knock people out. No, with
powerful I was like how's he going to
rhyme with that?
>> name is Ali needs Dawah.
When I give Dawah you feel the power.
Oho. I like my chicken sweet and sour.
You smell so bad, go have a shower. I
need I need to, I think.
>> No,
>> I'm not talking to you.
>> Okay. But if it if the shoe fits, I'm
joking.
>> [laughter]
>> I'll take that shoe still.
Guys, nothing else to be said. Anything
else you want to say? Some big boy talk
there, you know. As-salamu alaykum.